thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here
ken is with us from am I reading this
right Alaska yes sir welcome brother
good to have you good to be here you're
here to do your debt-free scream all the
way from Alaska yes sir I'm hoping they
hear it up there today I will have to
make it good and loud it's always up
there from Tennessee yes sir so what are
you doing Alaska work in the oil field
okay very cool very cool so did you fly
down drive down what combination taxi I
rode my motorcycle from Washington over
here about back in July and then went
back to work and I just come back down
here so we're out riding again me and my
buddy so okay yeah very cool so how much
debt have you paid off Ken $394,000 good
lord that's amazing yeah how long did
that take you I did it in 18 months whoa
you must have sold something what'd you
say I sold the house okay so I'm
homeless right now but I'm okay with it
no that's fine so how much did the house
sell for 245,000 okay so that's two
forty five of the 394 so you still got
like a hundred and sixty thousand bucks
right yes sir and what's your income sir
about 150 thousand here okay in the oil
field in Alaska HANA sir all right cool
so how did you do the rest of the
hundred and sixty thousand in 18 months
making 150 well we um
my job is a two-on-two off schedule so
we work two weeks on two weeks off and I
ended up doing three weeks on one week
off and my week off I didn't go anywhere
I didn't do anything in fact they picked
up little extra cash washing cars my
brother's garage mm-hmm detailing and
stuff and so I just went gazelle man
like nobody's business so you just went
crazy so what kind of other than the
house what kind of debt did you have I
had taxes credit cards furniture
motorcycles snow machine and couple
lines of credit what's the dumbest thing
you ever bought
well I don't know lots of stuff okay
what happened 18 months ago that made
you decide you needed to get out of that
and could get out of that I'd actually
gone to Michigan to see a buddy man that
was dying and so I spent the last bit of
money I had and the the end of my
credit-card line and I found myself in a
hotel room one night because I blew up
my motorcycle there in Michigan and I
was sitting in hotel room begging the
credit-card company give me another
thousand dollars line of credit so I
could make it back home I don't know how
I did it but I managed to get back home
and I said I'm done with this ain't
living like this no more especially with
the money I make and that's what it was
and I just started January 7th they
wrote down all my debts littlest the
biggest and I just nailed them yeah you
did man you went after it out very cool
so how did you get connected to us
listen to the radio up on up in the oil
fields up there we get you're on there
every day from 9:00 to 11:00 all the
boys are up listening right now to me so
oh cool yeah so yeah that's how I got
hooked up with it and buddy mine kind of
got me you know steered that way too so
yeah
but you had to have that moment in that
hotel room where you said I'm sick of
this I'm too old to be living like this
I make too much money to be living like
this it's time to fix my life a min
they're good for yes indeed proud of you
man thank you that's very very neat now
very cool so what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is and the
sign of goal the weight off your
shoulders mm-hmm
like freedom mm-hmm that's oh I mean
nobody owns me no more mm-hmm have you
ever been without debt uh yeah when I
first started in oil field I got out of
out of debt and then I just got caught
up and went normal yeah very nice buried
myself and and uh I don't think I'm that
normal anymore
no you're not that's for sure brother
yeah I love it yeah welcome to weirdness
a mess where we have a club that you
have joined I'll tell you that yeah I
love it that's fun how old are you
uh actually two days ago I hit the big
five oh good for you
yeah very cool oh very cool so uh what's
the story I saw the helmet when you came
in you got like a Viking Viking horns on
your helmet or something was there a
story to that or you just you just like
being a character combination both I
bought a few years ago when I was out in
Sturgis for the motorcycle rally it fits
in there yeah yep and so and whenever I
have to wear a helmet in the States down
here that's when I wear for here they
pretty much can't not see me out with
that on yeah it does help the drivers to
notice yeah yes and that way they don't
run over you yeah very cool our state is
one of the ones that requires that so oh
there it is yeah for those of you at
home watching on the watching on the TV
now you get to see the helmet it's got a
mullet built into it oh yeah I got no
more - yeah she got your own so it's a
continuation of your own that's good
very fun you're fun brother thanks very
cool so what advice do you give people
who are trying to get out of that
because you've done an amazing thing
here three hundred and ninety four
thousand dollars paid off is no small
step dude you were this is impressive
yeah it just got to hold onto that that
light at the end of the tunnel and when
you get there you'll owe so worth it
that it was amazing and the guys at work
you know kept telling me I was crazy for
doing them long hitches three and ones
and
doing anything else is your craziness
I'm telling him I'm getting this done
I'm doing it mm-hm and well when I paid
that last one off and the release I mean
there was just there's nobody owns me
that is just amazing in my bank accounts
been going yeah it goes crazy because
you have nothing to do with it I mean
you know you make 150 thousand bucks a
year no payment you get some money piled
up pretty quick yes indeed that's uh I
have been playing a little bit since
then no but uh well you've earned it you
live like no one else later you get to
live like no one else
yep so I get back in the game here and
yeah a little more normal here when I
get as far as their life goes but you
don't ever be normal financially again
no you cut up all the credit cards of
course yes first thing I did and whether
that was fun I like that yeah no more
yeah so tell people how it feels to be
free you'll hear in a minute when I do
my screaming alright that'll do alright
Ken you're a lot of fun man Alaska three
hundred and ninety four thousand dollars
paid off one hundred and sixty that cash
flow to forty five eventhough else he
did it in 18 months working on the oil
field threes and ones $150,000 your
income count it down let's hear a death
free scream three two one
all right that is fun that's fun guys if
you do not have the app to watch the
show happen you can get a free a free
app for your iPhone or your iPad you can
watch it at Dave Ramsey comm / Dave you
missed some pretty cool moments
I mean you missed a guy who really fun
that was a lot of fun you missed his
helmet you missed his hairdo but you
missed his passion - you could hear it
on the radio but man when you see it
it's just you got to be watching
especially the debt-free screams you got
to be watching them so that's why we do
it we do an HD TV show version of this
live it's nothing special when it's me
on it's like watching an ugly tank drive
but you can watch the whole thing right
and so again you can get a free app at
the end in the in the App Store and
download it for your iPhone or iPad or
you can watch it at our website and it's
mobile friendly for the other versions
okay
so Dave Ramsey comm / Oh get in there
learn about it watch this thing about a
half million people watch it so you need
to be one of those and it's very very
well done our team spends a lot of
talent and money to make sure it's well
done every day both of those cost money
but anyway it's very well done so oh man
that was cool and you I wish you'd seen
well you can see it it's on 24 hours a
day 7 days a week see go download the
app right now and in about three hours
you can watch it because when I go off
the air that the show starts over again
and goes and stays on 24 hours a day
until I come back on this is the Dave
Ramsey show
alright folks if you just saw the
powerful story from Ken from Alaska he's
here on the bike Dave is coming out to
congratulate Ken how awesome very cool
that is a blast absolutely awesome
beautiful bike tell us about the bike
actually was one of my one of my debts
that I paid off quick it's a 2010 road
cane I don't then change allowed just
handlebars and I just love riding it's
my life and so hell yeah total freedom
yeah thank you yeah the helmets coming
there it is folks there's your special
treat you're gonna see this hey come
here for a second Dave real quick
because he was overcome with emotion as
he was sitting here folks waiting for us
to come back live he's sitting here and
I just want you to share you know you
said it was amazing that you don't owe
anything anybody nobody owns you but now
the release what's going through your
head and heart right now just racing
just overwhelmed and want to break down
that's huge what I'd like to see a
powerful man like this just realize the
sheer emotion of the journey look at the
emotion unbelievable it's fun it's it
shows that there's more to this than
just math this is not just a math
problem it's not just a money thing
because what he kept saying over and
over is right I mean the borrower is
slave the lender you don't own me
anymore nobody owns me anymore it feels
different to ride a bike down the
highway man when you don't know anybody
that's a real freedom
that's very cool stuff for those of you
watching out there on your journey if
you see the emotion right here this is
what it looks like and feels like out of
the way yeah that's true so here you are
all right so now you're an oil worker I
really want people to understand how
hard work the oil fields are and how
tough just physically is this kind of
work it's it's pretty demanding my job
is not quite as demanding physically
anymore but it's still busy it's a lot
of long hours minimum twelve hour days a
lot of overtime and we're leave
sacrifice allowed were gone gone from
family and friends he'll for that time
that
work and we work in racking the Arctic
200 miles above the Arctic Circle so
it's not uncommon for us in the
wintertime to see 30 40 below and have
to be out working in that stuff so it's
yeah so sacrifice and you get to where
I'm at is was huge it's so great to see
this so we got a we got to ask are you
going to drive this all the way back do
you stop in Washington fly back what's
the journey now I gotta work with a lot
of friends that commute back and forth
from from Alaska and work lived down
here in the States and I'm just going
riding and enjoy some time some freedom
some real freedom now that's good you're
out on the road but you're really free
so are you just gonna take off you're
gonna go a couple days what do you
think's next the actual next little stop
here any idea downtown Nashville live it
up tonight Nashville it's fantastic
well thank you so much for sharing a
part of your story this is cool this is
what we've all been waiting for here
people want to make fun of me because
this this helmets amazing tell us about
the helmet while I put this on super
fast um I got it next 20 years go out
and Sturgis and uh one buddy out one and
so I got one and I got to wear a helmet
that's when I wear now I want you to
look at me real quick and be honest how
goofy do I really look wait goofier me
that's a fact folks but hey it's worth
it when we get to be a part of stories
like this yeehaw
you